at Hong Kong's Wong Tai sin Temple
thousands are welcoming the year of the
rabbit this Temple is well known for its
fortune telling practice known as
kalchin most visitors come here with
hopes for the coming year
I'm here to pray for luck I wish to have
good health earn more money and stay
happy with my girlfriend
with political unrest and the pandemic
recent years have been difficult for
Hong Kong and the territory is now in a
sharp economic downturn but many want to
put all that behind them this is the
first Lunar New Year holiday since Hong
Kong eased most of its covid-19
regulations temples around the city are
resuming Customs that weren't allowed
when pandemic rules were still in place
worshipers and visitors returned to this
Temple since it restarted its practice
of burning incense this week
to eat the measures before the new year
so that people can celebrate together
at West Kowloon station thousands of
people from Mainland cities are crossing
the border with Hong Kong for the first
time in three years
we visited many times before the
pandemic we come from Shenzhen and we
love Hong Kong
the rail network suspended operations in
January 2020 and only resumed them this
month
we are here to visit our family in Hong
Kong I haven't seen them for three years
and I missed them economists say the
recovery for Industries hit hard by the
pandemic won't happen overnight but
there's reason for some optimism this is
creating a confidence that when the
mobility is there will be like a retail
sectors growing mall growing and also
it's supporting the business that
already has been three years suffer from
the pandemic
[Music]
as people gather for festivities with
their families many are hoping this year
will be much better than the last
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Hong Kong